[Music]
if there is one thing fans like more
than watching their favorite movies it's
ranking every aspect of them the batman
the latest in a storied history of
batman movies provides fresh fodder for
fans so the real question is pattinson
vs bale who really played the better
batman the dark knight has been played
by so many actors at this point that you
would be hard-pressed to find a person
who doesn't have some sort of ranking
for the collection of actors and their
respective portrayals it used to be that
a favorite batman could be separated by
generation it's now more apt to compare
batman performances based on intention
and tone than anything else especially
when you consider the thematic valleys
between say george clooney and batman
and robin and ben affleck and batman vs
superman dawn of justice some of the
performances however are easy to compare
arguably the two closest being christian
bale and robert pattinson bale portrayed
batman and christopher nolan's famed
dark knight trilogy while robert
pattinson debuted his version of the
caped crusader in this year's the batman
both depictions of batman examine the
early years of the vigilante through a
lens far more grounded in reality than
other more fantastical comic book movies
but which actor do fans think did a
better job bringing a darker dark knight
to life director christopher nolan's
batman begins became one of the most
critically acclaimed comic book films
ever when it was released in 2005
winning near universal praise from both
critics and fans fans have continued to
show support for bale with the actor
even being voted the best batman in a
poll this year from gamespot out of more
than 290 thousand votes bale received 66
percent of the support as the best
batman against competitors ben affleck
adam west and michael keaton while
nolan's the dark knight is the highmark
for many fans regarding batman movies
some are already declaring robert
pattinson and the batman superior even
though the film was only just released
i'm vengeance like bale pattinson has
also won over critics with the batman
currently standing at an 85 percent
fresh rating on rotten tomatoes critic
christie lamyer drew comparisons to
robert de niro and taxi driver in her
review for roger rogerebert.com she said
this is travis bickle in the bath suit
detached and disillusioned he's not just
prepared but hungry to explore this
figure's weird dark instincts there is
plenty to compare when looking at the
performances of christian bale and
robert pattinson in their respective
batman projects both actors turned to
edgy adaptations of the character after
careers building respectable
performances and challenging pieces bale
performed in movies like american psycho
and pattinson more recently with indie
films such as the lighthouse both have
also earned similar praise for their
debut portrayals of batman a character
each shows as a brooding figure as the
beginning of a journey of possible
addiction to his vigilante persona
between the two however bale is the
favorite this may not always be the case
but with three highly praised movies
under his belt bale has earned more
faith with audiences
next to the recent game spot poll
crowning bail as the fans favorite by a
wide margin there is also a 2020 survey
similarly finding bale on the top of the
batman heap while the batman has earned
plenty of praise too bale's movies
remain more universally liked with the
dark knight touching 94 percent with
critics and audiences alike on rotten
tomatoes even the dark knight rises
earned higher marks with critics than
the batman while pattinson is not
dethroned bale it should be noted that
the batman is only his first film and he
hasn't been included in many public
polls if the reviews are any indication
though pattinson could soon be replacing
bale for many as their preferred dark
knight
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]